senard d'aller à l'école bon je me veux
tu l'as compris se vend ce truc de fou
cd c'est pas céder contre walid regardez
moi ce travail vous pouvez lui poser une
question qui a découvert les états unis
d'amérique
c'est un grand air la fouille des fils
c'est pas vous ne les dégager
mais pourquoi ce sera à nous de
récupérer c'est comme ça ils vont ruiner
la réputation notre établissement cette
harpe un mot je rêve fou de nous la
voici notre mascotte c'est skippy sa
vraie vie d'un manque d'un vrai
les gars je crois qu'il me regarde de
travers
exceptionnel les gains exceptionnels ce
que je vois là oui on est amis à
blizzard les riches seront produits
contrefaits peuvent lui démontrant
comment basse vitesse parce que tu fais
ça marchera jamais entrevu visite à
l'opposé elle c'est la réussite et toi
tu lis clubs
européens vers la paix côte à la télé
que même le mien tu as maté les moins
que j'ai là tu matin la bouche
le maire vous dégagea pas de l'année de
quoi tu parles on n'a pas le brevet ils
vont nous virer pour toujours on va le
faire pour l'honneur pour la gauche
quartier que si vous le faisiez
seulement pour leur prouver que vous
avez votre place je suis donné à la
soirée d'intégration sans dégâts j'ai un
caillou dans la chaussure
mais tu m'as bien fait très mignonne
bruay des collèges pour récupérer votre
honneur
[Musique]
depuis la nuit des temps les espaces ont
traité d'imbécile ça va changer ça non
vous serez toujours des imbéciles mais
des imbéciles avec un diplôme
là c'est les stylos tranquille c'est moi
c'est un chien fou quoi